elle avait réuni les habitants du
village et des communes voisines
quelques jours après la mort d'Emma une
marche blanche est à l'époque organisée
les proches de l'adolescente prennent la
parole devant plusieurs centaines de
personnes
tous les jours parce que nous on va en
avoir besoin
et je vous remercie tous
beaucoup d'émotions beaucoup de
tristesse également et comme je vous dis
on sent toucher et qu'on aurait pu être
ça aurait pu être nous quoi il y a pas
de mots pour expliquer ce qui s'est
passé tenter de comprendre
l'incompréhensible ce 9 juin 2022 au
petit matin le corps d'Emma est retrouvé
tout près de son ancienne école primaire
la dépouille de la jeune fille présente
de nombreuses plaies et un couteau
encore planté dans le cou dès le
lendemain le petit ami de l'élève de 4e
est interpellé au collège de l'uni où
les deux adolescents étaient scolarisés
très rapidement le garçon passe aux
aveux sans antécédent judiciaire le
suspect avait évoqué à plusieurs
reprises sa volonté de tuer sa petite
amie avec laquelle il entretenait une
relation émaillée de rupture et de
réconciliation l'examen psychiatrique du
garçon avait conclu à une altération
importante du discernement mais sans
abolition sa responsabilité pénale est
donc aujourd'hui engagée dans ce procès